so how are we going to beat this novel
coronavirus by using our best tools our
science and our technology in my lab
we're using the tools of artificial
intelligence and synthetic biology to
speed up the fight against this pandemic
our work was originally designed to
tackle the antibiotic resistance crisis
our project seeks to harness the power
of machine learning to replenish our
antibiotic arsenal and avoid a globally
devastating post-antibiotic era
importantly the same technology can be
used to search for antiviral compounds
that could help us fight the current
pandemic machine learning is turning the
traditional model of drug discovery on
its head with this approach instead of
painstakingly testing thousands of
existing molecules one by one in a lab
for their effectiveness we can train a
computer to explore the exponentially
larger space of essentially all possible
molecules that could be synthesized and
thus instead of looking for a needle in
a haystack we can use the giant magnet
of computing power to find many needles
in multiple haystacks simultaneously
we've already had some early success
recently we used machine learning to
discover new antibiotics can help us
fight off the bacterial infections that
can occur alongside SARS Coby two
infections two months ago
Ted's audacious project to prove funding
for us to massively scale-up our work
with the goal of discovering seven new
classes of antibiotics against seven of
the world's deadly bacterial pathogens
in over the next seven years for context
the number of new class of antibiotics
that have been discovered over the last
three decades is zero
while the quest for new antibiotics is
for a medium-term future
novel coronavirus poses an immediate
deadly threat and I'm excited to share
that we think we can use the same
technology to search for therapeutics to
fight this virus so how are we going to
do it we're creating a compound training
library and with collaborators applying
these molecules to SARS Coby to infected
cells to see which of them exhibit
affective activity these data will be
used to train a machine learning model
that will be applied to an in silico
library of over billion molecules to
search for potential novel antiviral
compounds we will synthesize and test
the top predictions and advance the most
promising Kennedy since the clinic sound
too good to be true well shouldn't the
antibiotics AI product is founded on our
proof-of-concept research that led to
discovery of a novel broad-spectrum
antibiotic called hallasan allison has
potent antibacterial activity against
almost all antibiotic resistant
bacterial pathogens including
untreatable Pam resistant infections
importantly in contrast to current
antibiotics the frequency at which
bacteria develop resistance against
Allison is remarkably low we tested the
ability of bacteria to evolve resistance
against Allison as well as cipro in the
lab in the case of cipro after just one
day we saw resistance in the case of
hallasan after one day we didn't see any
resistance amazingly after even 30 days
we didn't see any resistance against
Allison in this pilot project we first
tested roughly 2500 compounds against
e.coli this training set included known
antibiotics such as cipro and penicillin
as well as many drugs that are not
antibiotics these data we use to train a
model to learn molecular features
associated with anti bacterial activity
we then apply this model to a drug
repurposing library consisting of
several thousand molecules and ask the
model to identify molecules that are
predicted to have antibacterial
properties but don't look like existing
antibiotics
interestingly only one molecule in that
library fit these criteria and that
molecule turned out to be Alison given
an Alison does not look like any
existing antibiotic it would have been
impossible for human including an
antibiotic expert to identify how often
in this matter
imagine now what we could do with this
technology against ours Kobe - and
that's not all
we're also using the tools of synthetic
biology tinkering with DNA and other
cellular machinery to serve human
purposes like combat in Kobe 19 and of
no we are working to develop a
protective mask that can also serve as a
rapid diagnostic test so how does that
work well we recently showed that you
can take the cellular machinery out of a
living cell and freeze-dry it along with
RNA sensors onto paper in order to
create low-cost diagnostics for Ebola
and Zika the sensors are activated when
they're rehydrated by patient sample
that could consist of blood or saliva
for example it turns out this technology
is not limited to paper and can be
applied to other materials including
cloth for the Cova 19 pandemic we're
designing RNA sensors to detect the
virus and freeze-drying these along with
the needed cellular machinery into the
fabric of a face mask where the simple
act of breathing along with the water
vapor that comes with it can activate
the test nuts if a patient is infected
with SARS Kobe - the mask will produce a
fluorescent signal that could be
detected by simple inexpensive handheld
device in one or two hours a patient
could thus be diagnosed safely remotely
and accurately we're also using
synthetic biology to design a candidate
vaccine for Kobe 19 we are repurposing
the BCG vaccine which have been used
against TB for almost a century it's a
live attenuated vaccine and we're
engineering it to express SARS Kobe -
antigens which should trigger the
production of protective antibodies by
the immune
system currently BCG is massively
scalable and has a safety profile that's
among the best of any reported vaccine
with the tools of synthetic biology and
artificial intelligence we can win the
fight against this novel coronavirus
this work is in its very early stages
but the promise is real science and
technology can give us an important
advantage in the battle of human which
versus the genes of superbugs a battle
we can win thank you
[Music]